oh hi reject nation John does it better
hi gray I do this impression for you
gray or high reason there's John
Humphrey that was for great for you we
are going to watch a top rewards here
request from Marvel Studios the room no
that's not from this from Tommy Wiseau
is YouTube channel Jason Dolan patron
video requests the timing wise oh you
spread yourself you request video
he was like you have to cover this for
my video request as mom
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh no he should be Chris are you under
her French where's my money Denny I'm
just sitting here thinking how are you
like killing people think they shot this
film using so with that magic hand you
can't like make [ __ ] soy beans or
something yeah for like almonds edamame
nothing just snap my fingers they would
all cease to exist and I call that mercy
lay off the roids bro
serial killers are very strange these
days
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh wow
oh my it's the Gregory Brothers the guys
who did the you know it's climbing in
your windows he's snatchin your people
love those guys auto-tune the news this
video has taught me one thing and that's
if you are one of those people who's
famous for making something so bad it's
good what you should do is lean into the
memes and and do YouTube because that's
the place just do your thing and people
will love it and they'll and you'll just
make that ad money well I thought that
was [ __ ] hilarious yeah that was so
damn funny it's so weird me how does the
whole thing with Tommy Wiseau and then
the room it's been so long I thought
that would the disaster artist coming
out that like okay maybe we got like
another six months more and it's gonna
peak and we're gonna get so sick of it
right somehow we're not sick of it they
do this and this just reinvigorates and
brings a whole new life and perspective
and it is this is catchy as [ __ ] yeah
I would listen to this song this is
something not in a way of like that's a
great song but it's just so damn catchy
and if you're in the know of what it's
about you see how their music is evolved
to because this was like very modern
very like since she's got those like
trap percussive elements with the
Skinner II high hats and stuff and then
it sounds just like a lot of the popular
like synth R&B stuff that you would hear
now
just through yeah this horrific filter
of you know room quotes there were times
when this was a little uneven just as
like a comedy bit but I did appreciate
that they often would commit to having
them be scenes between like when they
were splicing live
even in the beginning once they actually
broke into a song anything really just
came into funny position and smoothed
out oh I love the and the hyper style
editor reminds me of like Aldo Jones
editing style yeah or like Brody quest
or some someone that viral video like
that something like that yeah I
appreciate that they also got Greg
Sestero return to actually shoot some
additional for this instead of just
plopping sort of moments out of the room
which they did throughout but a lot of
that splicing was really well done it
was super funny and anytime you just
thrown the meme of any of you quotes in
the room it just seems to work for some
rule and that's the other thing too is
like half the room is shot against a
green screen anyway so it's like I'm
sure it lenses any number I got a tip my
hat I guess - Greg Sestero and Tommy
Wiseau in a way for at least flowing
with what they got you know I like how
this is up on Tommy Wiseau his main
channel do it wasn't participating
participating in his video he's probably
busy or something
this tear just looks sad at the end of
this video a little bit I could never
tell what his vibe is now all I know
from his real life is the disaster
artist movie where dave Franco played a
super ambitious want to be an actor
who'd seem like you probably actually
had some real talent that isn't still to
this day being as fully utilized as it
can be but maybe best friends is gonna
be that next step maybe then best
friends come in a long time ago yes well
maybe it's gonna drop on home video
maybe it's our chance to see it now that
it's coming home okay that might be in
well I would like to check that out my
duty I hear I heard was actually pretty
damn good yeah I heard I mean that's the
thing too is if you if you get
collaborators who really know how to do
it whatever weird thing they're doing if
you can work well this is a catchy song
there's gotta be a spot we can purchase
this at I loved the storytelling
dynamics to the song as well how first
is just the references to the room and
then you get like a whole verse it's
dedicated to Marxism and then at the end
of any part where he's turned that I was
like you predicted yes sorry
yeah I think that was a great or teef of
light in the way you are retelling the
room story is spliced with the infinity
war end game story and I mean it was so
rewarding to have the leave your stupid
comments in your pocket line actually
have a bit of umph when he crushes yeah
I thought to whatever they
the dialogue of the other Avengers the
way they've manipulated as a mouths yeah
really worked that's where they kind of
reminded me a lot of weird trailers yeah
this is really well done Tommy Wiseau
could use your help he's only at 21,000
followers on YouTube million really
trying to make it big here so subscribe
to the Tommy Wiseau YouTube channel who
we did meet now it's cool touched him
touch a photo with the man subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell
Jason Dolan thanks for requesting this
buddy buddy old buddy Jason helped us
get into Joe Manganiello
Oh Harvey look out at comic-con listen
I'm not gonna be one of those guys
that's telling Jason my those guys who
waits in line to talk to famous person
Joe Manganiello
but I'm looking at the room and
everyone's is waiting like winking at
sneaking and getting my turn so Jason
and I we chatted for a long time
right near Joe because apparently Jason
knows him and I'm not gonna wait in line
but honestly whenever he accidentally
made but my arm or something like that
oh my god Jason I wouldn't have had the
experience of having an in-depth arm
bump with jell-o jell-o mango tell you
buddy so thank you for that never washed
that arm again I haven't or Mike balls
you